[Music]
hey what's up party people happy tuesday
that means it's time for honest trailer
commentaries i'm here with lana danielle
as always and today we're talking about
loki uh the series loki which i believe
can sit on the i everything yeah yeah
there's actually a taco place i really
like called loqui loq ui that's a sign
for the point uh we're going to talk
about the honest trailer we're going to
get into our uh deepest thoughts and
feelings about it we're going to show
some deleted scenes we're going to
respond to comments and questions from
viewers like yourself so keep them
coming in the chat and then we'll tease
you with next week's honest trailer um
sorry to digress at the top but i don't
have too much to say about loki except i
really enjoyed this series uh what'd you
guys think i like all the weird marvel
stuff i like when they get weird a whole
lot because a lot of it is so very
formulaic um there wasn't a lot of that
they diverged from a lot of like the
usual marvel tropes that we see
i really really enjoyed it yeah i i
don't really again i don't have a whole
lot to say about it up top like we'll
get into it as you know like the little
kind of nitpicky stuff as the trailer
goes along but overall i thought that it
was really good and i hope that they do
more weird stuff and that's kind of what
i'm looking forward to in this next
phase
please please please get more weird
because we're kind of over like they're
like i don't need more of blank hats i
need more weird stuff
yeah yeah you're right after black widow
and falcon and winter soldier this is a
nice palette cleanser and kind of a
reminder of what marvel does well which
is cosmic uh bizarre antics and and
bright colors uh all making jokes at
each other but in a good way i think in
this instance in a very good way uh what
do you think lon
i i feel like i really like the middles
of all of these marvel shows they always
kind of start and i'm like it's a little
slow like can we let's get to it and
then the last episode always feels like
very compromised like what we got to
like
segue this back in
to fit into the larger universe and in a
way that if you haven't seen the show
like maybe there's a few details you're
not picking up but you still like get it
uh so it always makes like for a weird
season of tv but episodes like two
through five of loki i think are awesome
and the fifth episode where they're in
the void with richard grant we we talk
about it a lot in the trailer uh that i
love and i think it's like one of my
favorite just like standalone marvel
things in a lot yeah
yeah um but i think that they uh
aside from whether the tone is is like
cosmic or grounded i think they did a
really good job
character-wise uh with loki or
loki's if you will like this is
something that i feel like he's always
been a character where most of his um
depth has been uh created or um
projected onto by fans because they just
love tom hiddleston so much and they
want to see him uh
he's so pretty he's so pretty he's the
prettiest boy um
but this really did give you uh
a really really deep uh a kind of
unpacking of of this guy's various
insecurities and stuff like that and and
and like a smart way to kind of bring
him back to life and then take him
because they'd already kind of developed
his character through end game but to
bring him back to when he was still
alive and then develop him in a kind of
a different direction i thought was
really a genius way to keep one of your
most popular characters and actors on
board and like make me excited to keep
him around
uh rather than just kind of a hackneyed
way to oh loki again because we can't
think of anybody else so i definitely
appreciate the character work on this
one
yeah i think that's the thing that
they're doing best with these disney
plush shows is the movies it's like well
we've got we've got to service 12
characters like even in the smaller
scale movies like the ones that are
focused on just one hero it's still like
black widow it's like we got to deal
with elena we got to set up rachel weiss
it's david harper's characters we got to
set up ray winston and there's all this
world building there's all these other
members of the ensemble but these shows
they could really delve a little bit
more into the psychology and the
personal experiences of wanda and vision
in the case of one division or you know
not only i guess falcon winter soldier
but even baron zemo and some of the
other people in that world and in fact
aware soldier and then yeah this one we
get to really get more of a feel for who
loki is rather than just his like
chaotic presence in these stories yeah
and then yeah in regards to the ending i
mean look it's it's a good ending in a
meta marvel fan kind of way of like oh
the implications um you know the
implications uh for for the multiverse
and all this stuff implications
like in that sense it's a huge uh ending
but they just it like we said the
trailer like they didn't dramatize it
it's just a dump it's just he just shows
up and he's doing his best man he's
doing great he's a great actor but he's
just dumped the next position on you for
so long i know we say it's 11 minutes
long but it's actually much longer than
that it's just that one section of it is
11 minutes long um that's no way they're
only cutting i know
yeah you're showing me all of these
great visuals i get to see all of these
great things and then we end on just
like a monologue and like you said he's
doing his best like he really is like
we'll get into it in there like he's
really trying to make this visually
interesting but it's like you know
what's visually interesting showing us
stuff the way that you have the like
show don't tell is a reason is a thing
for a reason and it's just a lot of
telling and that monologue got so long
um that was like the one part like
literally my one low point in the series
and it wasn't because of the actor but
it was just because like i don't want to
hear anybody talk for 11 minutes that's
just too many minutes
it's too many minutes otherwise very
tightly paced action-packed show um it's
just funny like it's what we've been
saying since one division when everybody
was like mephisto's gonna be he's gonna
drop in at the very end and be like i'm
the devil i've been doing everything and
and we were like no that would not work
in terms of storytelling because he
hasn't been part of the show all along
so it's not dramatically satisfying to
just bring him in at the end as the deus
ex mocking explanation and then that's
what they did and well i mean that's
exactly what they did like five episodes
of this show and then episode six is
like here's the answer and it's like the
final episode of one division didn't
work either which is just them flinging
goo at each other so right you can't win
at least they had the good sense to make
the the villain pivot was a character
we'd already met that we were already
somewhat invested in it was like here's
a new wrinkle on this person that you
didn't know that i think i i agree that
the one division fidelity had its own
its own issues but at least i feel like
they did a better job of integrating the
villain into the show rather than having
it be this big question mark that then
we we like turn over a guess who card
and it's answered and then answered and
then answered again yeah and it's like
right and it's like okay it's that guy
and i'm sure he's going to be important
and if you are like there there are
certain kinds of fans and i don't mean
this in a condescending or a
mean-spirited way it's okay to be like
but there are certain kinds of fans
where they're just they're into the
narrative they're just watching this
stuff for like tell me what happens next
tell me what happens next and i'm sure
it was riveting from that perspective
because it's a huge clue
unlocking the next phase of marvel but
if you're watching these for the stories
of the characters of the narrative i
don't i don't know if it's as big a
payoff yeah yeah i'm not necessarily
looking for like i i appreciate when
there are these little nuggets for to be
continued but i don't want the whole
last thing to necessarily be like and
the question will be answered and then
it feels like when they do those huge
crossovers um which is part of the
reason why i've like sometimes uh taken
breaks from comics because i'm like i
don't look i love reading comics but the
whole thing of like and the next issue
will be answered in avengers number 1078
it's like i don't know i'm just gonna
wait for the graphic novel like i don't
know that i'm gonna do one there you go
it's like when you read a book that's
got a ton of footnotes and after a while
you're just like i'm exhausted david
foster wallace like i i'm sure there's
brilliant i'm sure there's great nuggets
down there but like i just want to read
a thing all right we won't do the
infinite jest commentary uh yet um
we'll get there we'll get there next
time let's let's start the uh let's
start the honest trailer and see what
else we have to say
[Music]
meditations on america's betrayal of
black soldiers but now a marvel series
is ready to take on life's biggest
question
how long would it take for you to do
yourself
i'm at a weak tops right
loki yeah and someone like loki like now
that minutes killed off its only
um as a joke but not really uh whiplash
in that grid of marvel keeps killing off
all their good villains because you know
we have a soft spot on whiplash in this
show
it's more his board yeah
but it is funnier to say uh that one of
the best villains in the mcu is tony
stark and from a certain point of view
it's definitely he definitely is not
even from a certain point of view at
this point i think by the end it's
almost just text it's not even subtext
we're gonna get in trouble by people who
say that we don't appreciate what tony
stark gave up for us
when he's posthumously gifting
international drone assassination
programs to teens i think we'd be like
this guy crossed a lot like
yeah well yeah as ryan says in the chat
billy still gets flashbacks from that
tony stark's the bad guy uh essay he did
there is like a die hard uh defend tony
stark at all costs fandom and um you
know what yeah whatever fictional
character if that's who you that's who
you identify with go go ahead you uh you
stunted billionaire you i
i'm sorry that people are tony stark
hasn't solved world hunger
i feel like look he started off well i
think if you go back to like iron man
one very defensible i just really like
it i think iron man i think he got
better as time went along i think he's
very indefensible environment what
diamond one is a redemptive arc it's
like he started off bad but then he went
good by the end it's by like i don't
think so by the end he like basically
becomes blackwater he becomes like a
private military corporation of his own
accountable to no one like this is well
he's just right yeah only himself well
that but that's just superheroism in
general like superman doesn't answer to
the us government
uh
well that's what bbs was all about and
that's that's important
yeah we'll do it please welcome our
special guest an infinite jest
i want to know
sorry to prune so many timelines we got
to we got to stick to loki let's keep
watching loki we'll talk about it
and do a speed run through three movies
worth of character development
i love you my sons remember this place
but honestly i'm glad they made the show
tom hiddleston hasn't been this charming
since that pov chinese vitamin
commercial probably be a bit busy for
the next few weeks
but um
i'll make it up to you soon i promise is
he supposed to be my husband or are we
having an affair either way
yeah
was this famous i've never seen this
before it got brought up in this
discussion for on australia it's hard to
say if it's famous or not i know i've
been a fan since i decided because but
like did this go viral when it was new
or is this just a thing you know it's
viral anymore you know if a million
people see a video is it does does it
matter um i don't know uh i think that
this was absolutely a fascinating uh
commercial because i'd never experienced
the like first person perspective tom
hiddleston dating simulator before and
it almost blinds you to the amount of
questions i had mostly about the meal
he's preparing i guess we show that
later we can we can get into that later
but uh danielle what's your take on this
uh on centrum silver brought to you by
tom hiddleston dreamy
[Laughter]
yes please make me your favorite meal
not mine make me your favorite meal and
feed me vitamins you pretty pretty
long-haired man
it's her favorite meal because he says
like black pepper how you like it like
black pepper on top
it's very clever that they filmed it
like in portrait mode so you can watch
it on your phone and it really fulfills
the fantasy of like you are facetiming
with tom hicks he's talking to you i
mean
landscape landscape mode it's just
another commercial portrait mode it's
like oh okay this isn't this is the one
on my series though with every actor
that you might have a crush on
um
and just do
like i don't know
uh no that guy's
who dead you like a pov vitamin
commercial from let us know in the chat
yeah
all right let's keep playing who could
convince you to take some time to escape
the clutches of the tva a bunch of time
cops tasked with
[Music]
you get no nutrition today
this place is a mess
i guess he's like exasperated constantly
well
i don't know what's taking some things i
have to go
i'm making a sequel to john adams
i'm john quincy adams this time okay all
right uh okay well miranda's just
winking at you no oh just the lip bite
like
[Music]
oh i went to a bodega yeah
do you know what that is um okay anyways
keep going keep going my sacred duty to
try and make the word prune happen they
want to personally oversee the variance
pruning tva has pruned a lot of these
guys prune on site no no pruning she's
already been pruned just prune it let's
bail so you're gonna prune me or he
pruned her prune it prune him she's self
prone watch them clean up the mcu
timeline
because apparently the only version of
events that's allowed to happen is the
one where a rat saves half of existence
and captain america goes back in time to
beat his own ass
take a number tommy boy because this
isn't just a showcase for one loki
there's an entire comic-con's worth of
variants to cosplay as like sylvie the
femme fatale who spent her life camping
out in various ragnaroks making it hard
for her to trust someone i can't sleep
around untrustworthy people who was i
thinking trusting you because you can't
trust
and i can't be trusted and even harder
for her to open up to the possibility
that she might just want to do herself
and i mean come on most people do
themselves every day like multiple times
a day and the timeline is just fine
trust me
i just
i'm sorry
i would make out with my own clone i
just think that most people would either
sure that's the thing i think that
that's if you could you would i don't
think it makes sense to get grown like
people were acting like they were
grossed out by this idea that a
loki and another loki from a variant
timeline in the multiverse would get
together and it's like it's too
impossible to think it's a girl like we
we know that you can't even picture that
happening so it's not gross well it's
just marvel is so like and i get it
they're all pg-13 movies and they're
largely for children that it's like
they're they're so icked out by sex and
stuff like any time anybody's about to
make out somebody like cracks a joke or
is like ew or or they're interrupted by
an explosion or something like that but
they canonically even in this show
they're like i'll bet you had lots of
princes and princesses after you and
like yep yep we were all bowing down all
the time but then and he's the god of
mischief he wouldn't immediately like be
like all right let's see what happens
now like people are acting like this is
ann twins but like they're not twins
they're like from different universes
well but i wonder if like they certainly
their children would probably be
alligator loki if they actually
because that's where alligator loki
comes from i know they're very
inspirational when two loki's love each
other very much yeah that is a variation
in the in the in the dna there for you
to get anything other than an alligator
so i i i get the revulsion there but uh
you know
they'll they'll be smart about it
anyways uh yes marvel he could just put
on protection just by going like this he
doesn't they don't have to be prepared
yeah
yeah i just
even though i liked the way the the
romance uh uh played out between the two
of them it just doesn't you just have to
take it as just a given that
loki's
who are all supposed to be these like
lothario like playboy and play women are
like suddenly acting like awkward high
schoolers like when they're when they
meet
another version of themselves it was
cute but it didn't really track for me
they'd be all over each other anyway
just keep going
still let me spend her whole life alone
it makes sense she would be like weird
and not socialized loki i i i i see
you're getting yeah
fine
trust
me there's classic loki proving that
richard e grant can make you love any
character even if he's dressed like
kermit the frog and talking nonsense for
30 minutes straight kid loki who
murdered thor but like kid thor all you
have to do is dangle a candy bar near a
wood chipper and let nature take its
course alligator loki he is an alligator
and chinese vitamin commercial loki what
you can't tell me that's not an
extremely health conscious loki berry i
mean just look how many vegetables you
make me for breakfast oh so many
vegetables
for like four people
yeah
that's a huge serving you could not eat
that by yourself and like one egg come
on dude
you'd be on the toilet all day that's a
lot of roughage first thing yeah
i gotta feel like that the amount of
roughage he's giving you either he's
transformed you into a horse or um
he's
uh that's to symbolize how much is in
like one pill of centrum you know
like the like one pill of syndrome is
one like a
hubcap size breakfast salad equals one
center
of this bowl of cut up peppers and corn
is that what's in there
there's definitely a whole strip of it
that's just corn niblets which i don't
feel like is an american salad thing
yeah well put maybe a little bit of corn
what is he
why does he say
i finished early what is he finished
what
i i think it's supposed to be he
finished work and because he he says in
the beginning like i'm going to be
working like i'm going to be really busy
but i'm going to make it up for you this
is like right finished early so but but
what work is he doing
yeah i think it's it's him in the
morning
going to his
tom hiddleston job and then yes him
returning later
okay all right anyways so it's dinner
eggs being he's being tom hiddleston
he's off you know being a full-time job
making japanese commercials and loki
why is he so like apologetic about
everything i think it's an affair i
think he's this is a mistress simulator
um i feel like it'd be a longer more
fleshed out discussion if they were
married oh i thought i thought you were
saying this was the wife and when he
says he's going to work he's actually
going to be with another woman in a
totally different
product conversa
yeah interesting
uh does he have is it his house or her
or her house like
does he travel with an apron
i think he brings the i think he brings
the apron with him i think he's that
like conscientious that he just like has
an apron he's so thoughtful i just i
like the idea that he's got partners all
over town and they're all recording him
but for different ads
in another woman's house it's just like
you know i put fresh goodyear tires on
the car they really hold up the best
under rough conditions
and they're all variants and that one is
the that that makes sense that was the
alligator loki
that's why it's a hubcap worth of food
that's why
vegetables
all right keep playing i want to hear
more theories in the chat
yes let's keep playing bureaucrat is
obsessed with loki and jet skis which
makes him the perfect partner for the
man who's also obsessed with loki's and
jet skis c jet ski plus
i kept waiting for that to pay off of
like he's going to do the jet ski thing
because that's what i that's the first
thing i thought about it oh he was on a
jet ski in the avengers like so there's
going to be some timeline thing where
he's a he's on a chitari jet ski and
they're like both yelling and screaming
and having a good time but but no season
two i feel like they are holding this in
their pocket for like the final shot of
the final episode will be loki and uh
mobius finally getting to go on a on a
jet ski adventure today i feel like
they're they're saving this for the big
set okay fair enough oh i hope it's like
the end of like that one episode of
eastbound and down where it's just lucky
without a shirt on just like waving it
around
you and i
is that photo of of p diddy in the in
the bathrobe uh holding the champagne
bottle on a jet ski i think they should
recreate that with owen wilson
just jet skis throughout time yeah does
he does he shove red slayer off the jet
ski
you know we'll see we'll figure it out
uh all right keep going then there's
judge rinslayer an evil bureaucrat who
discovers that she's actually middle
management not upper middle management
like she thought
gasp miss minutes just one of many
multimedia presentations this show has
to use to explain what's going on
without your eyes glazing over
your salad
is asgard no don't do it sounds good
and kang the conqueror this annoying
theater kid variant journey to the
hogwarts at the end of the universe to
meet marvel's next bad guy with a thing
for purple and thrill as after five
episodes of fast-paced excitement kang
plops into the series like the architect
from matrix2 if he also did improv he
can't kill me because
i already know what's going to happen i
think my design was quite naturally
perfect it was a work of art flawless
sublime ryan says kang would do ground
links over ucb and you're right
[Music]
i wasn't sure this was gonna play
because their delivery is so different
but it really does but it works really
well ages
and ages of cosmic harmony this scene is
11 minutes long
when marvel too many ones on that minute
called up rick and morty writer michael
waldron to run the show and he's
bringing along a grab bag of wildly
original concepts like portal guns
space lizards space lizards barely
escaping planets before they're
destroyed speeches about how existence
is chaos existence is chaos nobody
exists on purpose nobody belongs
anywhere everybody's gonna die hide
minds me i presume if anyone's anyone
you're me my passion for unification you
mean stealing people's bodies summer
rude tech that's always running out of
jews
characters very precisely and cunningly
breaking each other down psychologically
insecure need for validation would
motivate you to find the killer you act
like prey but you're a predator you use
pity to lure in your victims that's how
you survive getting drunk during big
missions you're drunk no
i'm just full but bear in mind i'm very
full and time prison you know what they
do to third dimensional life forms in
time prison same thing they do in every
other prison only forever wow where do
they get all these ideas i guess there
was nothing left to steal from jack
kirby huh it's a pause
i just get the sense that they marvel at
some point must have like
backed a dump truck full of money up to
like dan harmon and justin roiland to be
like do marvel stuff and then they like
talk to them or like try to like
have them do something on a schedule or
something and then the dump truck full
of money just pulled slowly away from
their studio
this does kind of keep happening because
mike mcmahon who is also a rick and
morty writer he's the guy doing uh star
trek lower decks now so it's like they
go to the other rick and morty writers
who still want to have a career and
they're like you do the ip because dan
harmon he can create his own stuff and
uh you know justin roiland must be uh
he's busy yeah he's fit he's busy they
just sold like 17 seasons or something
of rick and morty he's gonna have to
crank that up for well they have to take
a month off to make the season finale so
you know they're right there right up
against it they're right up against the
timeline
uh and yeah this guy uh michael michael
waldron is also doing uh doctor strange
too so yeah look i think that's it's a
perfect fit for and rick and morty is is
riffing on other sci-fi tropes
we could have taken them both back to i
feel like doctor who was like the
granddaddy of both of these kind of
takes off this sort of sci-fi like
anything goes crazy multiverse there are
no rules with the salty old protagonists
who've seen it all yeah like yeah i feel
like that really is is they're both kind
of riffing on on hey
i wrote this run and i'm aware it's not
totally fair i just thought it was fun
well there you go
also it's funny that michael waldron he
did rick and morty he did loki and he's
also doing heels that new stars
wrestling show like he's just a
renaissance man he's got a lot of
interest sounds like a a man after
danielle's heart that
good times all right keep going crap in
for what's ultimately a small scale
series that manages to feel huge thanks
to massive animated establishing shots
like when you witness the apocalypse of
this world from an empty crater enter an
infernal nightmare bureaucracy that
stretches to infinity
now let's retire to this
to the office at the center of time and
reality but quick into their bowling
alley
so if you're picking out a smartphone
i mean this didn't feel like a small
like intimate uh you know office
procedural it felt big and i think that
they were it was a smart mix of of these
massive uh like i said massive
establishing shots and then everybody
get into the little tv set that's
practical um i i think they they use
their budget well because yeah you know
and there were some like there was that
uh
you know uh 1917 on acid uh uh shot
where they're running through the the
city being destroyed and stuff like that
like they use they use their money well
they they definitely had an awareness of
of this and and did a few scenes where
they try to like split the difference so
it is like you get some of loki and
these other loki's wandering through the
void it doesn't feel like they
immediately retire to their underground
bunker but they do get there before you
know too long it's like they're there's
it's budget conscious but with an
awareness and a cleverness about how to
be budget coach yeah it's also not like
overwhelming for six episodes you know
what i mean like it's because because
you look at especially that shot of the
tva and like how huge and massive it is
and that's just you could do a whole
season just in all of those different
space needles so like sure that would be
like a difficult thing so i'm glad that
like it's they found a way to scale that
down that was good
yeah the only time i felt it was a
little confined was that finale just
like meet the lord and creator of the
entire universe in his like nicely
appointed traditional 80s style home
office and it's like all right you know
the whole show will wrap up and the
characters will be in these like cushy
chairs around the desk
uh hashing it out oh okay i feel like
visually maybe could have come up with
something for that he should have gotten
at least like one other kang stepping
through a portal maybe even yeah like
kang's on loki's you know whatever well
waiting for something to open that
up a little and then no it's just dark
just dark room okay dark office
all right keep playing be stuck with
content like a foie gras goose enjoy the
show that gets you ready for a movie
that gets you ready for the next wave of
the mcu that gets you ready for season
two of the show that gets you ready for
death and as long as they keep making b
plus content while keeping every good
actor from doing anything original this
machine is going to keep cranking until
we're all in water world darkest
timeline
starring
loki on god
be a lady
the setting crashers
bf kangs the old guard
he who rehashes
gators will say it's fake dramatic
weapon achieving for my next trick
love
is a dagger find a way back to the tva
fine
betrayals i've never stabbing her in the
back that's such a boring form of
betrayal judge wren slayer really feel
betrayed by her beloved tba i guess she
don't do partners unless of course it
benefits you and you intend to betray
them at some point how do i know that in
the final moments you won't betray me
you betrayed me no no you betrayed me
you betrayed me you betrayed me oh grow
up grow up apologies
parts of this reminded me of the show
remind me of um
is it dear sister what's the snl sketch
where they're reading like you walk in
and shoot me
i was trying to figure out a way to play
that but couldn't think of it
but i thought about it when i was
working for that yeah exactly
i think we covered it
centrum vitamins chinese department
doesn't shut us down
all right keep going apologies my leash
i betrayed you about that
you can't be serious my throne about
that
and hair flips
yeah i wish i had flippable hair angle
chrono things get in the way
you know this never would have happened
if tony stark could just let hulk use
the elevator he really is responsible
for every bad thing in this universe
there you go that's why he's in that
grid
um
good times i i i think we made something
out of nothing there and i only say that
because uh it's tough when i watch
something and go oh i really enjoyed
that that was fun
okay now yeah nine minutes worth of
jokes about it well especially because
this is the third of these disney plus
marvel shows and they were all you know
pretty good like i i liked some more
than others some episodes or whatever
but it wasn't like any of them was like
a huge flop that was easy for us to goof
on yeah so like they're not doing us any
favorites here
yeah um by simply work on your quality
control yeah i want either and decrease
it
please yeah i want bad movies makes our
job easier
um
your job however is simple just hit the
like and hit that subscribe and we'll
take care of the rest kick back pop open
to bud light lime and enjoy um because
we're doing this every week
how many of those do you have left are
you still working through those just a
single b double l you know um i'll have
to do when is a good time when are you
in the mood for one but light luck never
that's never good
i'm also almost out of dish soap so
i can do it by another six and then it
really does it all
uh
all right so we have um some outtakes i
imagine uh let's see what those ended up
being
the only version of events that's
allowed to happen is the one where a rat
saves half of existence and captain
america goes back in time to beat his
own ass yep history has always had to
play out exactly this way for all time
always
and a space jam 2's worth of janky
looking background loki's
and there's more to moby than meets the
eye this tva analyst has the superpower
to act exactly like owen wilson big
metaphor guy i love it
starring
loki
loki prime
as guard as it gets
god james god my pear lady time bandit
stuck with the hiddle and you
shanghai literally whenever
that's hansel he's so hot right now and
also every other time drill bit time
lord
judge snooty
doppelganger a black sheriff the last
conqueror in san francisco
kermit
void rage
gatorade
power measuring contests you all parade
about as if you're the divine arbiters
of power in the universe we are you're
not
[Music]
blades are worthless in the face of a
loki sorcery
a swing of a mess
not bad
guilty of this
he's trying to use his powers ma'am
don't rush me
damn it why would it work
the horn identity
free will hunting
doctor who done it
impractical jokers
yeah i want to do that last one just to
piss off joe um i always gotta have an
impractical because he's such a big and
practical jokers fan uh everyone tweet
him your favorite impractical jokers
clips and quotes
uh
all right so uh on to the questions um
timothy reynolds asks what's your
favorite loki variant
oh well i liked boastful loki until he
got all betrayed um but i liked sylvia i
think
yeah i like sylvie sylvia was probably
my favorite loki variant just uh
by way of getting most of the character
development i guess yeah
uh centrum silver loki feels like an
excellent life mate and somebody who'd
probably be really terrific to live i'd
probably be healthier if i lived with
him but i'm still gonna have to go with
alligator well but it depends on how
much time he spends with you because i
get the feeling that he kind of he kind
of hits it and quits it like he's he's
there he's he's like giving you a lot of
attention and affection and he's like oh
something came up at work i'll see you
in a couple weeks just just a meal just
around meal time otherwise
nowhere to be seen yeah
i now love this maine loki prime i don't
know what what you call him the the one
that got plucked from the avengers um
he's definitely definitely my favorite
loki's definitely the most interesting
to me but you know i'll just say the
alligator because
everybody loves a cute animal
right animal in a place you didn't
expect um a mouse in a vest can i
introduce you in a mouse and a vest we
got one of those now you know
uh let's see uh james zuniga uh now that
we have three marvel series do you think
this is enough to say you have a
favorite series or
a favorite by default this is my
favorite
i'd say it's it's a level above the
other two those two are like tied for
second and this is like a this is a
solid like wow i can't wait for season
two and the other one's like i enjoyed
my time
um i think just because i'm such a fan
of television one division is still got
like kind of a special place in my heart
just because of the way that it did that
i will say the further away it got from
like the weird tv stuff um the less i
kind of liked it like i don't i'm not a
huge fan of the flinging of goo but um
yeah i would say that like just for for
the examination of that and watching all
the actors do something different then
everybody who work on it do do something
different one division's got like a
little place for me okay
uh yeah i think loki is my favorite
although i really like the the major
poor stuff in falcon winter soldier
their falcon winter soldier had stayed
more of a globetrotting
like espionage adventure
and less like the sort of where it where
it ended up i think i would probably
have enjoyed it more but but i think
overall loki is probably my favorite
uh major part looked like it could be on
like an alternate dimension in loki or
something on a different planet um maybe
it will in season uh alyssa hawkins asks
would it make sense to have season two
be a side story to the mcu timeline or
because we have a multiverse is there no
point it's similar to a question from
matt pierce expect kang to have more of
a presence in season two than the mcu
movies like is kang a loki villain or is
this a
uh
or is this a he's gonna be the next big
bad in the mcu
oh that's a really interesting question
um i kind of feel like at least this
version of kang black kang um
we know that like oh ryan is saying we
know he's an ant-man for sure yes he was
originally cast to be the main villain
in ant-man three so we know
that that's like at least one other part
of this story beyond that who's to say
i'd be surprised if you're an ant-man
bill i'm sorry i'd be surprised if
you're an ant-man villain if you end up
being the one pulling all of the strings
in like the mcu
i'm sorry i don't know shade to ant-man
but that's just that's just the hard
facts um
quantum realm though like ant-man's the
key to the quantum realm and that ended
up being
like a real major hub for a lot of the
stuff in this universe so yeah
we'll see
yeah they now have an excuse to do
anything they want which is i think the
goal like cast anybody they want uh
recast anybody they want all they needed
crank kang to do is to crack open the
multiverse and anyone can walk out of
those portals now yeah i think i think
like ken probably will be some kind of
presence in doctor strange too but i
would be surprised if he's the main
villain in multiple upcoming films like
thanos got a two-parter that he was the
main villain for but it's not like he
was the main villain for the whole phase
it's like you send ronin after this one
and you know you come up against uh
jude law whose name i forget and captain
marvel in this one you know
uh
why didn't i go for another villain
character whose name i remember anyway
you got what i'm saying you get what i'm
saying then i i feel like i feel like
he's maybe gonna be a presence but i
don't know if you'll be like the key
villain in all
uh
yeah i agree um and now closing out with
uh with a tough one that i can't really
decide i gotta think it over adam
holbert asks who's the best marvel tom
tom hiddleston tom holland or tom hardy
those are three heavy hitters though oh
venom
like somebody else pointed out this that
that um
uh fastballer wrote that is the casting
of total unknown tom hiddleston the best
gamble the mcu has ever made i gotta say
it's up there like plucking him and and
most of the chris's out of not obscurity
but uh
semi-obscurity or tv or something like
that
they're really doing well um in the
casting department but i gotta say look
obviously tom hardy's the best actor out
of the three of them but
confined to just their marvel roles i
think hiddleston is is on top
um i gotta say holland i think that just
like his he did such a good job i think
that that's such a hard role and i think
that it's really hard to step into
something we've already seen so many
times um and despite the tony stark of
it all i think that he was able to
really like
i you know he was able to be a really
convincing peter parker and i think that
um especially like it helps that he has
that dance background maybe i'm just
thinking too much of his lip sync battle
which will always i think yeah
yeah the umbrella dance i'm just i'm
voting based on the umbrella dance
that's it that's all it is you're just
voting based on the fish tank scene in
venom so well i was gonna honestly i was
gonna say uh i'm tempted to go with
heart i i feel like tom hardy and
michelle williams in venom it is not my
favorite movie but the two of them are
acting like they're not playing it like
it's a funny one-off like they are
bringing the same energy and focus they
would bring to a manchester by the scene
like i don't i don't feel like we're
getting
partial tom hardy in that movie he's
going for it and and that's what makes
that movie watchable because the others
you know it's
not poorly made
or it's not well made in any other way
um
so yeah so i i almost feel like if we're
just talking about just just purely the
performance and the the acting and
nothing else i might go hardy well i
mean for me it's tom and i think that uh
hiddleston i think that might be you
know most improved over time because we
knew he could like show up and chew some
scenery but in this one like there's
some real uh
depth and pathos and he can do the
comedy he can do the leading man stuff
like he's right and
we also point out it was a gamble to
cast him in some way but they also
wouldn't have put him in all of these
various projects like loki wasn't
necessarily a character that was going
to be a linchpin for the whole marvel
universe it is now because everybody
loves tom hiddleston in that role yeah
so it was a gamble but
it it you know like if it hadn't worked
out well they would have just focused on
a different character yep well there you
have it and uh speaking of stars
that's your clue for next week's honest
trailer
see what i did there you'll see what i
did there um thank you danielle thank
you lon thank you audience uh we will be
back next week uh for another one and
back tomorrow for more sju thanks for
watching everyone see you later
[Music]
you